one of the great things about this
year's ccma awards which you can see
right here on global sunday september
27th
is that you're going to see some great
performances with artists like dallas
smith to neil towns
tim mcgraw and kane brown and when it
comes to kane
it's pretty safe to say we're going to
hear something from his new ep
mixtape volume one but here's the
surprising part
he actually told carlos that john legend
inspired him
to change the way he sings this ep is a
cool project man
mixtape volume one this is a really cool
thing i love that you co-wrote like
every track on this but it's also really
cool to see the collabs on this thing
like between john legend nelly swaylee
khalid
were you able to be together for uh a
lot of this recording or is it
mostly like the magic of technology
yeah no the only song that i actually
recorded in studio with the guy was john
legend
i'll never be perfect i'm
gonna try to do
better i swear
[Music]
i'm glad i was in the studio with him
because
he kind of made like he made me sing
differently
just because i made him go first and i
got to watch him sing
like for that song i'm literally fully
projecting
which i don't ever do like i'm just you
know
super chill i literally was watching him
fully belting i felt like he was being
my vocal coach from the voice
and so when i sing that song now
it's easy to sing that song because i
know how to predict it now but i don't
know
it was really cool being in there with
him he did a lot of stuff that a lot of
artists don't do
so it was cool getting the witnesses
[Music]
would be a dream collab for you for any
projects coming up
i think i'm gonna have to go for like a
shania twain
okay you know because we've done so many
pop collabs recently
i think the country collabs to complete
this mixtape
[Music]
how does it feel for you to be able to
uh be on this journey
but be with your family like be close to
home
have you know have your daughter
experience this with you
man it's a it's a blessing uh that
this happened and i get to hang out with
her and just you know
be at the house with they're not on the
road but honestly it kind of sucks too
because
we were you know this is like the early
days to get her used to the road
she's been on the bus like two to three
times i think by time we get out like
she's gonna be realizing what's going on
and if we ain't been on the bus and then
she forgets what it was it's like
how's that gonna be you know we're doing
shows around all these people
so luckily she's been around my team so
hopefully she's pretty socialized she's
like a true quarantined baby you know
she hasn't been around other babies and
experienced anything
like luckily she's only she's about to
be 10 months old but she she's
her personalities came along so much
like she realizes a lot more than we
think